umgestürzte bäume zertrümmerte autos der
winter orkan hat deutschland mit voller
wucht getroffen
eine erste bilanz von polizei und
feuerwehr zeigt aber die schäden sind
bislang weniger schwer als befürchtet
auch weil viele vorsichtig und gut
vorbereitet waren am frühen morgen hat
der sturm den süden deutschlands
erreicht in niederbayern auf der a 93
richtung münchen stürzten bäume auf die
fahrbahn chaos im berufsverkehr in baden
württemberg gibt's bei pforzheim ein
unbeladener sattelzug um auf zwei autos
einen kleinwagen begräbt der auflieger
komplett unter sich niemand wird
verletzt
weiter im norden zeigen sich am morgen
die sturmschäden aus der nacht in
frankfurt wurde kurz nach mitternacht
der ausleger eines baukrans in das dach
des doms gedrückt wie groß der schaden
ist kann noch niemand sagen
diese aufnahmen eines im sturm landenden
flugzeuge es gestern abend in london
machen die runde
der pilot muss dann doch durchstarten zu
gefährlich entscheiden viele
fluggesellschaften streichen hunderte
start am morgen gibt es am größten
deutschen flughafen in frankfurt noch
immer etwa 200 abgesagte flüge
während in münchen immer noch flieger am
boden bleiben müssen normalisiert sich
der betrieb in frankfurt langsam wieder
bei der bahn fahren im norden die ersten
züge wieder die letzte nacht mussten
reisende noch in dafür bereitgestellten
zügen verbringen
wir haben seit dem frühen morgen die
strecken mit lokomotiven abgefahren von
teil auch mit hubschraubern
um zu sehen ob sie frei sind auch die
gefahrlos befahren werden hören oder
vielleicht noch bäume drohen umzustürzen
erst aber ganz sicher sind dass alles
sicher ist können wir auch grünes licht
geben
den ganzen tag wird noch aufgeräumt
werden das ganze ausmaß von sabine wird
erst dann klar sein